[Applause]
true i am so honored and thrilled to be
sitting here talking to you i mean
to have watched you as a young child
and seen all these iterations of your
life and the way you've
handled everything like i'm so excited
like i have chills talking to you right
now i'm so excited thanks for having me
okay i had a whole question lined up for
you and now my mind just went blank
because i'm living in the bliss of that
and that makes me wanna go to a
different question which is i
love that you've embraced this notion
of your book about second acts
and the reason what you just said meant
so much to me
is because i think about it in tandem
with this notion that you're putting out
so strongly into the world and really
owning and running with this concept
that i think we all
need to really buy into and believe
because it gives us the courage to
change our tracks
when it seems really scary and
intimidating we don't want to ditch
everything we've learned and
known or that's safe how do we
uh take that risk patricia
you know this is so interesting because
the pandemic
gave everyone this pause in their life
men and women and by the way of any age
to take assessment of how they've been
spending their precious time and we've
all realized
how precious life is through this
pandemic and how precious our families
are
and i i feel that a lot of people and i
know that a lot of people
have thought when we can get back to
life again
i'm not sure i want to be living it the
same way i was doing before the pandemic
um but what how do i change that
and so there's these wonderful stories
in your second act
uh really inspirational stories by
people i've known personally and others
that i just heard about who i invited to
be part of the book
who because of financial circumstances
medical circumstances
um you know just uh uh various reasons
have had to pivot yeah and you know i
feel like
you've done that in so many ways like i
don't know you're like on your fifth act
and the only thing left for you to do is
become an international spy
i mean i think that's going to be your
sixth act uh by the way
thank you for giving me a brand new goal
um i really love your second act which
just came out in paperback and we're
celebrating that today
because risk-taking is great but
how we take that risk is really the key
so thank you for
really actually writing a manual on how
to do it
you're welcome now okay it's mother's
day
and we're just all moms you have four
sons yes i know and it's so funny when
you're talking about um
tattoos because you know i'm a little
bit older than you drew
and i had said to my sons from the
beginning i saw this tattoo
thing starting to really infiltrate the
culture and when i was growing up
only sailors and bikers got tattoos
i literally said to my boys anybody gets
a tattoo
is out of the will and
wait so how's that going okay
so there's only two left in the will
no actually my oldest son went to
college
and he came home for thanksgiving break
and
he came to the set of the middle when
there were 100 extras on the set
so that i couldn't get angry at him and
announced that he had got my heart
too oh my god what a smart boy smart guy
of course he had all the crew members
coming over saying like hey man cool
tattoo and they all started showing him
their tattoos
right so i was like okay first of all we
have to finish the scene so i can't even
respond
and um and then um i you know he showed
me the tattoos it's like
five eyes like just an eye in five in a
row on his forearm like eye eyes
yes like an eye yeah that sounds really
cool well
okay thanks drew thank you
it's original and unique does it
represent something
okay so that's why i said okay i said at
least tell me
that it means something and i could see
him in his mind
like all he thought was oh that's cool
so he goes like um
each eye represents my one of the
members of our family and i'm like
you're bsing me and so he has a few more
and my another son has a few more and
you know who knows anything can happen
but if i do drew if i get one it's going
to be
massive i do it i am going all the way
gosh i wish you were here today i wish i
could strap you to that table
of ryan one of the most famous tattoo
artists
in the world i mean by the way i heard
your um
sons have recently also gotten on dating
apps is that true
now listen you know i'm getting up there
and they i i'm like it's gonna be a
while before i have grandkids i had i
stopped drinking
because i thought i need to keep my
brain like
solid because the grandkids aren't going
to be here for another
10 or 15 years i don't even know if that
and i want i don't want to be that like
drooling nana in the corner
who everyone just walks over and kind of
you know has to give her a kiss and then
you know i just want to be involved and
active so yeah but they don't even have
girlfriends yet
two of them said they signed up for
dating apps and i was like yes
my husband and i are those weirdos who
like if we're walking down the street we
see somebody with a baby we like
stop and have to smell their head and
you know
you know people are like that's a
pandemic on stay away from my kid
but we both have baby fever i love it
[Music]